I'm Melissa.
And today, I'm
going to be talking
about how to achieve a seamless
workflow between R, Python,
and SAS, all
from within RStudio.
Now we're at an
RStudio conference.
And more specifically,
right now,
we're in a session that's
called Some of my Best Friends
Use Python.
So I already know that
everyone in this room
loves at least three
of the words that
are in the title of my talk.
But before we talk
about R or Python,
I first want to take
a moment to talk
about something that
I know we're all
even more passionate about.
Which, of course, is SAS.
Don't worry.
I'm totally kidding.
I was not referring
to SAS here at all.
I was actually
talking about food.
And I apologize in
advance because I
know we're still about an
hour away from our lunch
break today.
But I do just want
to take a moment
to talk about food
before we go any further.
I love food, but I'm
not a very good cook.
So I really like
these meal kit boxes
that you can get
delivered to your door
because the recipes are
always super straightforward
and they always come
with the exact right
ingredients measured out in
the exact right proportions.
And usually if I follow
along with the steps
in the recipe in one of
these meal kit boxes,
I can get the results to look
pretty close to the pictures
that are in the recipe.
But there's just one problem
with these meal kit boxes,
and that problem is that
they give bad cooks like me.
False confidence.
These meal kit boxes
have me thinking
that I'm totally capable of
recreating these masterpieces
totally on my own.
But a few weeks later, if I
try to reproduce the food,
I don't have all of the
ingredients available
and suddenly I have to start
making some substitutions
and all of a sudden
my food can end up
looking a little more
something like this.
And I find that the same can be
said for a lot of programming
tutorials.
If you have all of the right
ingredients measured out
in the exact right
proportions, then it's
pretty easy to follow
along with a simple recipe
and get the desired results.
But if you're missing
some key ingredients,
then you start having to
make some substitutions
or find some workarounds.
And then you'll end
up with something
that's perhaps technically
edible, although certainly less
than ideal.
And that leads me to the
outline for my talk today.
I'm going to be discussing
how to incorporate these three
languages into your
workflow, but I'm
going to present it
in two different ways.
The first way is
an ideal approach,
and this approach is going to
be kind of like following along
with a simple three step recipe
where but the downside here
is that I'm going to assume that
you have all of the ingredients
available.
And the second way
that I'll present
is a less than
ideal approach where
you're missing some
key ingredients,
and so you have to
find some workarounds.
But before I jump
into that, I first
want to start by providing
some context as to why
this particular
challenge arose for me.
I'm an analyst at
Statistics Canada, which,
for those who are unfamiliar, is
an agency within the government
of Canada.
And Statistics
Canada is Canada's
official statistical agency.
And the particular challenge
that I face at work
is that my employer wants to
adopt open source programming
languages like R and Python.
But we have a legal
responsibility
to ensure that personal
information collected
for statistical purposes is
kept strictly confidential.
This means that when
we publish statistics,
we first need to use an internal
generalized system called
G-Confid, which is
a series of SAS macros
that prevents the release
of confidential information
in tabular data using
cell suppression
and controlled random
routing methods.
And G-Confid is only
implemented in the SAS
programming language.
And what this means in practice
is that many analysts and data
scientists at Statistics
Canada have to use SAS
as part of their workflow.
If they want to be able to
publish official statistics.
My typical workflow
at Statcan usually
looks a little bit
something like this.
I work with some
SAS data sets
that first get passed through,
some pre-written preprocessing
scripts that are
written in SAS.
And once the data are
ready to be analyzed,
I bring the data
into R and then I
do the vast majority
of my analysis in R.
But if I want those
results to be publishable,
then I need to bring
the data from R back
into SAS so that I can
use these G-Config macros.
And you can think of G-Config
kind of like a black box.
It's a series of SAS macros that
is completely uneditable by me,
and these macros are
themselves confidential.
So I cannot and I would not
want to implement G-Config
in any other
programming language.
So for this step, I
really do need to use SAS.
Once I'm finished with
G-Config, I bring those results
back into R for data
visualization purposes.
And as you can see,
my workflow really
does require me to be able to
go back and forth between SAS
and R seamlessly.
And while I myself don't
typically use Python at work,
I do have a lot
of colleagues who
would appreciate the
ability to incorporate it
into their workflow.
So all of this led
me to the question
is there a way to
combine these three
languages in the same
script in a way that
does not cause a headache?
And the answer is Yes.
And there are multiple
different approaches.
The most
straightforward approach
is a simple three-step recipe,
in step one of this recipe
is to gather your
required ingredients.
For this particular recipe,
the required ingredients are
the languages that you're
interested in using, plus Java
and the other ingredient that's
not pictured here,
but which really
is the most important
ingredient for making
this particular recipe
succeed, is admin privileges.
And if you don't have admin
privileges on your computer,
you might not be able to
get this recipe to work.
Step two of this
three-step recipe,
assuming you have all of those
required ingredients from step
one, is to install
SASPy, which is
a Python package that works
very similarly to how reticulate
works.
So just like reticulate is
an R interface to Python, SASPy
is a Python
interface to SAS.
The third and final step
of this three-step recipe
is to perform a couple
of system configurations,
and there's a lot of little
details that are in this step.
So I won't go over that
today for the sake of time.
But if you're interested
in following along,
there is a video on
my YouTube channel
that explains all of the
steps and includes an example
usage of combining these three
languages in the same script
using SASPy.
Now that was definitely the
most straightforward approach.
And the recommended well,
my personal recommended way
of how to achieve this workflow.
But if you have limited
control over your computer,
then it might not
be possible for you.
So in the next few
slides, I'm going
to present a few
alternative approaches that
will allow you to
combine SAS and R
in the same script
and sometimes Python.
The approach that you choose
is going to depend heavily
on what you need to do
and on how much control
you have over your computer.
And for the three
alternative options
that I'm about to present,
for all three
of them, there's
going to be a big trade-off between
complexity and usefulness.
The first option is to use the
SASmarkdown package, which,
as you might be able
to guess from the name,
is a package that
allows you to include
SAS chunks in your R Markdown
or Quarto documents.
This option has the
benefit of not requiring
admin privileges,
but the downside
is that there's no interaction
between SAS and R at all.
So what this means is
that the SAS data sets
that you define
in your SAS chunks
are not going to be
accessible to you
in your R chunks and vice versa.
For me personally, I really
need this interoperability
between these two languages.
So this particular option
isn't the most useful for me,
but this package does have some
really interesting use cases.
For example, if you're
a course instructor,
you could use this in order
to show your students how
to perform the same task using
multiple different programming
languages all in the same place.
Once you have the
SASmarkdown package installed,
it's fairly easy to switch
between the three languages
within your R Markdown
or Quarto documents,
and all you need
to do is specify
which language you'd like to use
in each individual code chunk.
If you want to use SAS,
just set the engine option
to be sashtml and you can
set the engine.path option
to be the file path to
your SAS executable.
To use R, leave the chunk
header as the default.
And to use Python, set the
chunk header to say Python.
And if you were to knit an
R Markdown document that
contains three chunks
that looks like this,
the result will be
something that looks like.
This the second approach
that you can use
is a SAS-first approach rather
than an R-irst approach.
When SAS is launched, there's
an option that you can enable,
which is called RLANG and
the RLANG that you see there
on the slide in all
caps, I should mention,
has absolutely no relationship
to the rlang package in R.
So this all caps rlang that
you see here is a SAS concept,
not an R concept.
The RLANG option
can be enabled
without admin privileges
and it's pretty easy
to move data back and forth
between SAS and R using
this method, which
makes this option quite
a bit more useful
than the SASmarkdown
package for my
purposes at least.
Once the RALND
option is enabled,
you can use proc iml in
SAS to execute R code
and in order to
execute that R code,
just use a submit statement with
the R option enabled and then
anything that you put
between the submit
and endsubmit lines will
be executed as R code
rather than as SAS code.
Now I mentioned that it's
pretty easy to move data
back and forth
between R and SAS,
and if you want to
go from R to SAS,
you can use the ImportDataSetFromR
subroutine.
And if you want to go in
the opposite direction,
so to go from SAS to
R, use the
ExportDataSetToR subroutine.
Both of these subroutines
use the exact same syntax.
You start by specifying the
name of the SAS data set
and then specify the
name of the R dataframe.
I mentioned before that
this option doesn't
require admin privileges,
but really that's
only partially true.
If you want to use this
method from base SAS,
then you don't need to have
admin privileges in order
to enable this RLANG option.
But if you're like
me, and if you
prefer to use an IDE like
SAS Enterprise Guide,
then you will need admin
privileges in order
to enable this feature.
If you are interested in using
this method from within SAS
Enterprise Guide, there is a
video on my YouTube channel
that goes through the
full instructions of how
to set this up.
The third option that I'm
going to talk about today
is the one that is the
most complex, but also
the one that's the most useful.
If what you really need is the
interoperability between SAS
and R, and if you don't
have admin privileges.
And if you want to be working
from within RStudio, and this
is actually the approach that
I was using myself at work
for the past couple of months.
Myself and a
coworker on my team,
as well as a colleague
from another part
of our organization,
worked together
to develop an internal R package
that contains a function that
allows you to take an R data
frame, manipulate it in SAS
and then return the results
to R as in R data frame
without ever leaving RStudio.
And this package is
not publicly available,
but you can easily come up
with a similar solution using
the same general
underlying principles
that I'm about to show you.
The first argument that
this function takes
is the name of the
dataframe that you'd
like to manipulate in SAS.
And here I'm just using
mtcars data set,
which is a data set that
comes built into R
and includes variables
about characteristics
of cars such as miles per
gallon, horsepower cylinders,
and so on.
The second argument
that this function takes
is the location to the SAS
installation on your machine.
And the final argument
that this function takes
is the SAS code
that you'd like
to apply to your dataframe.
This function assumes
that in SAS, you
have access to a data
set that's called in_df,
and then the SAS data
set that will eventually
get sent back to the user as
an R data frame is called .
out_df.
And the example
that I'm using here,
I'm just using the
frequency procedure in SAS
to create a frequency table
of the cylinder variable
from the mtcars data set.
And by executing just
those two lines of code,
the results from SAS are
brought to the user in RStudio
without ever having
had to exit RStudio.
In terms of the
actual implementation
of this function,
this function starts by
creating a temporary file folder
and then saving the user
inputted R dataframe as a dot
file in that
temporary file folder.
From here, a temporary
SAS program is created
and the user inputted
SAS code
is then inserted into that
temporary SAS program, making
use of proc iml and the
ImportDataSetFrom R and
ExportDataSetToR
subroutines that we talked
about a little bit earlier.
This temporary SAS
program is then
executed by sending a command
to the command prompt.
Enabling the RLANG option.
And then the temporary files are
deleted after the results are
brought back into R
and finally the results
are returned to the
user as an R dataframe.
We all love
R but there might be
times where we want
or need to use other
programming languages.
Tools like SASPy are
making this easier than ever
to combine multiple
languages in the same place.
But if these options are
unavailable or infeasible
to you for whatever
reason, then you
might be able to find some
clever workarounds if you're
willing to put in the work.
For me, it's been a
little over a year
of exploring all these
different options
and more in order to figure
out what's viable for me
in my workplace.
And I'm very happy to say
that as two weeks ago,
some changes to our
IT infrastructure
have resulted in Statistics
Canada employees being
able to use SASPy
without any issues at all.
Thank you so much for listening.
I'd be super happy to connect
on LinkedIn or wherever
if you want to chat
about this more.